What is the best way to diagnose or to find out if you have an autoimmune disease or diseases?
There's only one way to find out if you have an autoimmune disease and you do antibody testing.
So you could get antibody testing through your medical clinic that you go to,
but typically if you go in and say I think I have an autoimmune disease and they have to have
some justification for doing antibody testing because it's kind of outside the normal scope of
testing, but if you have a good medical doctor that wants to dig to find the cause, they might do
lupus testing or something like that. Now there's really two different classes of autoimmune
disease. There's systemic autoimmune diseases that basically can affect multiple cells, multiple
cell lines, multiple tissues. That's bad. That's not good, right? And then there's tissue-specific
autoimmune disease. So I have antibodies to my thyroid, my thyroid, lobulin antibodies or TPO antibodies
would be a tissue-specific antibody. So I have antibodies to my thyroid gland. So I can affect any other
tissues. The autoimmune disease itself is not. It's only affecting the thyroid. So
ruddy antibody panel is the thing to do. I like Cyrex labs. You could get just a lupus of
antibodies through lab core or something like that or access labs, but to get some tissues-specific
antibodies, you really have to go to more of a specialty lab as far as cost-wise to get it
to get an entire panel. Otherwise, you order individual things and it gets more costly.
Cyrex array five is a tissue-specific antibodies to more systemic or peripheral tissue antibodies.
Cyrex array seven x is more specific to neural tissue, so brain tissue, which we run a lot of
those panels. And those are very important to run. So people that may come in and have issues with
cognitive impairment of some kind, losing my memory and remember things, but it's good to run
an Alzheimer's panel. If anything's positive on that, then we run a Cyrex seven x, which gives more
tissue-specific to neural tissue. If you have antibodies to neural tissue, that's not a good thing.
Antibodies to any tissue, that's not a good thing. So again, like I said, the other question,
if you have self-antibodies, you have a diagnosed autoimmune disease. Everything else how you learned
to treat it was out the window. You have to treat an autoimmune disease very differently than
you treat any other condition. And quite honestly, a lot of doctors don't really get that.
So you'll even go to national doctors that say, oh, you have chronic Lyme. We're going to keep
you on cat's claw. Oh, it's a flare again. It's not in remission anymore. So we're going to put
you on vitamin C in cat's claw and this chronic Lyme protocol that is basically all immune stimulants
in the thought process that we have to kill this Lyme. It's the Borrelia is raised, it's ugly head
again, and it's trying to attack you. So we have to kill this bacteria. Well, that can, while that can
be true, the only way to know that is to run a Borrelia IgM antibody test to see if you actually
have IgM antibodies of a current infection, many times that will be negative or run a white blood
cell panel and your white blood cell panel are elevated. Then maybe you do need to kill an infection
an active infection or a lymphocyte panel where you're going to get very specific and you're going to
know whether you have a current infection or not. Most of the time, or I would say at least many times
people with chronic conditions like this, their symptoms, their flare is not from the infection
raising its ugly head again. It's from destruction of tissue that would you have antibodies against.
So you might have, you know, we've got a cold or something that if you just go get, if you catch a cold,
your immune system is going to flare to kill that cold. Or if your daughter comes home with a
strap infection, your immune system is going to flare to kill that strap. But when your immune system
flares and you have an increase cytokine presence in the blood and in the tissues, you will create
more white blood cells and to attack that which you have antibodies against. So if you have antibodies
against self tissue, you're going to damage more self tissue in that process. So you do not want to
flare your immune system. And that's the benefit of taking supplements that support
what are called T-regulation cells or T-reg cells. Vitamin D is one of those. People
like vitamin D is an immune, you know, stimulant. Well, it's really not an immune system. It's an
immune regulator. So if your immune system is suppressed, like you're trying to fight cancer,
if your immune system is suppressed, taking more vitamin D, get your vitamin D levels up. It's
beneficial. If your immune system is hyper-vegulate, in the case of an autoimmune response,
then taking more vitamin D can help bring that down. So there's some other things on the market
that are beneficial for autoimmune disease because they're really T-reg stimulators. You do not want
to take any immune stimulators. You want to stimulate T-regulation or cytokine suppression.
Totally different way to treat that. So you want to try to diagnose an autoimmune disease. You got to
do antibody testing. And then if it is positive, you've got to treat it in a totally different
fashion than you've been used to probably treat you anything that you know. So if I don't more
on our chronic health and autoimmune course, so my arms are all scratched to death from
we need the raspberries the other day.